uh one of the ways you keep yourself
humble like we mentioned with Jiu Jitsu
is doing some uh really difficult
challenges mental and physical
one of those you've done very recently
is uh the Murph challenge
and you got a really good time it's a
hundred pull-ups 200 push-ups 300 squats
and a mile before and a mile run after
you got
under 40 minutes on that
uh what was the hardest part
I think a lot of people were very
impressed it's very impressive time
yeah how crazy are you it was the
question I'm asking but it wasn't my
best time but but I I'm anything under
40 minutes I'm happy with yeah um it
wasn't your best time no I think I I
think I've done it a little faster
before but not much I mean it's um
um and and of my friends I I did not win
on Memorial Day one of my friends did it
actually several minutes faster than me
um but just to clear up one thing that I
think was
um I I saw a bunch of questions about
this on the internet there are multiple
ways to do to do the Murph challenge
there's a kind of partitioned mode where
you do sets of pull-ups push-ups and
squats together and then there's
unpartitioned where you do the 100
pull-ups and then the 200 push-ups and
then the 300 squats
in serial and obviously if you're you
know if you're doing them
unpartitioned then
you know it takes longer to get through
the 100 pull-ups because you you know
anytime you're resting in between the
pull-ups you're not also doing push-ups
and and squats so so yeah so my I'm sure
my own partition time would be would be
quite a bit slower but
um but no I think at the end of this
um
I don't know first of all I think it's a
good way to honor memorial day right
it's um you know it's this um
lieutenant Murphy basically this is one
of this was one of his favorite
exercises and I just try to do it on on
Memorial Day each year and it's a good
workout
um I got my older daughters to do it
with me this time they um
my oldest daughter wants a weight vest
because she sees me doing it with a
weight vest I don't know if a
seven-year-old should be using a weight
vest to do pull-ups but yeah but um
difficult question a parent must ask
themselves yes I was like maybe I can
make you a very lightweight best but but
I I didn't think it was good for this so
she basically did a quarter Murph so she
ran a quarter mile
and then did you know 25 pull-ups 50
push-ups and and 75 air squats then ran
another quarter mile and like
in 15 minutes which I was pretty
impressed by
um and my my five-year-old too so I was
so I was excited about that and I'm glad
that I'm teaching them
kind of the value of
physicality right I think a a good day
for Max my daughter is when she gets to
like go to the gym with me and cranks
out a bunch of pull-ups and I I I love
that about her I mean I think it's it's
like good she's you know
um hopefully I'm teaching her some good
lessons but I mean the the broader
question here is um given how busy you
are given how much stuff you have going
on in your life oh what's
um
what's like the perfect exercise regimen
for you
to uh to keep yourself happy
to uh keep yourself productive in your
main line of work
yeah so I mean I've right now I'm
focused most of my workouts on on
fighting so so Jiu Jitsu and MMA
um but
I don't know I mean maybe if you're a
professional you can do that every day I
can't I just get you know it's too many
too many bruises and things that you
need to recover from so I do that you
know three to four times a week and then
um and then the other day is
um I just try to do a mix of things like
just cardio conditioning strength
building Mobility
um so you try to do something physical
every day yeah I try to unless I'm just
so tired that I just need to
need to relax but then I'll still try to
like go for a walk or something I mean
even here
um I don't even know have you been on
the roof here yet no we'll go on the
roof after other things but it's like we
designed this this building and I I put
a park on the on the roof so that way
that's like my meetings when I'm just
doing kind of a one-on-one or talking to
a couple of people I'm I I have a very
hard time just sitting I feel like it
gets super stiff it like feels really
bad
um
but I don't know I being physical is
very important to me I think it's um I
do not believe this gets to the question
about AI
I don't think that a being is just a
mind
um and I think we're we're kind of meant
to
do things and like physically and and a
lot of the sensations that we feel are
um are are connected to that and I think
that that's a lot of what makes you a
human is is basically you know having
those
having you know that set of Sensations
and
experiences around that
coupled with a mind to reason about them
um but I don't know I think it's
important for balance to
to kind of get out challenge yourself in
different ways learn different skills
clear your mind